l'ours polaire est devenu un symbole des
changements climatiques dans l'arctique
mais un autre animal emblématique de
cette région un peu moins connue
pourrait bientôt le rejoindre les inuit
qui chasse le boeuf musqué dans
l'archipel arctique canadien depuis des
générations assiste impuissant au déclin
de cette bête qui a côtoyé imaginez-vous
le mammouth et jacqueline d'abord
expliquez nous comment vous en est venu
à vous intéresser aux boeufs musqués
dans l'article mais je travaille ici à
radio canada international pour le
projet bilingue regarde sur l'arctique
quant au new york times c'est une
partenariat qu'on avait avec d'autres
médias dans le nord pour comprend mieux
comment le changement climatique touche
les populations nordiques à
l'international alors ici au canada ça
faisait des années qu'on entend que les
bouffées musqué dans l'actif canadienne
commence être plus en plus malade on
études et se classe cette année pour
entendre pour passer du temps avec les
inuits pour entendre de qu'est ce qui se
passe et comment ça touche la vie parce
qu'on peut être qu'on réalise pas
beaucoup ici dans le sud comme on dit à
quel point les changements climatiques
ont un effet direct sur le mode de vie
des inuits souvent ici dans notre camp
on parle de changement climatique
on parle de dos polaire et on a oublié
des fois qu'elle est canadienne qui vit
dans l'arctique majoritairement les
inuits et les premières nations qui sont
en train de vivre les effets des
changements climatiques maintenant et ça
touche toutes les sociétés l'économie
l'infrastructure est aussi la santé des
animaux bien sûr alors on va regarder ce
reportage avec ces images incroyables
que vous nous avez apporté
merci
la colline à marana qu a passé sa vie
sur l'île de victoria avec son groupe de
chasseurs et traquent un troupeau de
boeufs musqués ou de breeton woods devra
comme ses ancêtres colline doit savoir
lire le terrain pour trouver les bêtes
le world gold corp
après neuf heures de chasse ce 70 km de
territoire
ils n'ont pas vu une seule bête j'aime
le double des ministres aujourd'hui les
chasseurs repartiront les mains vides
cambridge bay nunavut est un village
situé à environ 475 km au nord du cercle
polaire les boeufs musqués sont des
créatures fascinantes ce sont des
reliques de la période glaciaire à
l'époque du mammouth elie grand ours
génétiquement les boeufs musqués sont
uniques
ils sont proches d'aucun autre animal
ils sont la quintessence de l'animal
arctique de boeuf musqué est moins connu
que l'ours polaire ou le phoque
mais pour les inuits il est tout aussi
important pour leur subsistance leurs
économies il occupe sur le pde colline
david lane et chasser avant même qu'ils
sachent marché la chasse en arctique est
une activité difficile
elle se fait à l'aide de motoneige
coûteuse qui consomment beaucoup de sens
et auxquels on fait la paix
et plus les boeufs musqués se font rares
plus la chasse kutscher
prenez donc il est devenu si difficile
d'apercevoir des boeufs musqués près de
cambridge bay que nous avons dû nous
rendre au zoo de calgary pour vous
montrer ces images
les scientifiques comme les chasseurs
rumeurs qu'il y ait de moins en moins de
boeuf musqué sur l'île de victoria et
qui sont de plus en plus malade au coeur
de leurs préoccupations
ce parasite le vert pulmonaire la
prolifération du parasite serait
attribuable aux changements climatiques
durant les années 90 la température
était trop froide pour que le ver
parasite du poumon se développe sur
l'île de victoria
depuis quelques années il fait assez
chaud pour que le ver survivent et
prolifèrent
notre deuxième sortie avec les chasseurs
nous met à rude épreuve
il fait moins 42 après 8 heures à les
traquer colline aperçoit trois boeufs
musqués
il en a un mais la bête montre plusieurs
signes de maladie dont le verre
pulmonaire les chasseurs doivent
abandonner la viande
[Musique]
et si vous voulez en savoir davantage
sur ces sujets qui concerne l'article
vous invite à consulter notre site web
vous voyez l'adresse à l'écran des
reportages et beaucoup d'autres
informations
vous allez trouver sur ce site